thank all of you I'd like to thank the
book Korea for sponsoring this event and
I'd like to thank the Tompkins County
Library as well for allowing us to have
this wonderful room thank all of you
from coming out I wanted to just speak
about the book for maybe about 35
minutes so then we'll open it up for
questions and answers for about another
35 minutes so just to to warn everybody
in here this book came out of a
dissertation that I wrote in American
history at Cornell University in 1998
I've been revising it I began
researching it 1994 it's been a lot of
time in the John F Kennedy Library in
Boston and in the Lyndon Johnson Library
in Austin Texas and as I say in the
preface of the book I think maybe why I
wanted to research this topic Robert
Kennedy's Senate years the 65 to 68
period was probably back when I was just
a nine-year-old boy in San Jose
California watching Robert Kennedy's
victory speech late at night at the
Ambassador Hotel with Kennedy campaign
literature strewn around the house
because I had two uncles who were draft
age and they were out canvassing for
Robert Kennedy and I remember that the
sadness and the just the the kind of
despair that descended upon our family
when we found out that he had been shot
that night and gravely wounded I also
find the 65 to 68 period of social
change in this country to be the most
exciting period in the post-world War
two ERA with regard to race relations
you had the passage of the Voting Rights
Act
you had the rebellions and Watts and
Detroit you had Martin Luther King's
Poor People's Campaign in 1968 with
regard to the Vietnam War between 65 and
68 the u.s. commitment they went from
23,000 advisors to over 500,000
ground troops there was the initiation
of what Johnson called the Rolling
Thunder sustained bombing of North
Vietnam and the Tet Offensive in January
1968 which exposed what Robert F Kennedy
called the deceptive illusions of the
war in Vietnam the peace movement in
this country went from a smattering of
teachings on college campuses in March
1965 to a massive citizen mobilization
in the fall of 1967 there was also the
collapse of the ideological
underpinnings of Cold War liberalism and
the tearing apart of the Democratic
Party despite the enormous
accomplishments of the 89th and 90th
congresses with the passing of Medicare
Medicaid Vista headstart federal aid to
education consumer safety legislation
the war in Vietnam divided the
Democratic Party and weakened the New
Deal coalition robert f kennedy's role
as senator the junior senator from new
york in these events is unique political
odyssey he was central to a period of
social and political change in america
the pace of which the country had not
seen before and has not seen since going
up against President Lyndon Johnson was
no small task Lyndon Johnson had won the
1964 election and by nearly 16 million
votes he controlled the Democratic
National Committee the House and Senate
leadership he had the Gulf of Tonkin
Resolution in his pocket which gave him
carte blanche to do anything he wanted
in Vietnam basically the functional
equivalent of a declaration of war in
Vietnam he had no hesitation and using
the FBI to spy on people he considered
his political enemies including Martin
Luther King jr. in 1967 and 68 citizens
for Kennedy organizations the National
Conference for new politics the New York
political activists Allard Lowenstein
stump Johnson movement Kings poor
people's campaign and even Robert
Kennedy's primary campaigns when Kennedy
hesitated and taking on Johnson
despite his profound disagreements on
the war in Vietnam it was because Lyndon
Johnson throughout 1966 in 1967 had the
power to crush Kennedy politically it
was not until the peace movement grew in
size and momentum in late 1967 they gave
Kennedy the political leverage and
breathing room to make a direct
challenge against Johnson in the
primaries and he did challenge Johnson
in March 1968 against all political
wisdom which holds that trying to unseat
an incumbent president from your own
party is folly
defense secretary Clark Clifford
Clifford told Kennedy and Theodore
Sorensen this in a private meeting in
March 1968 clifford drew on the
experience of harry s truman in 1948 who
also faced challenges from within the
democratic party and he assured robert
kennedy that if he went up against
Johnson that he would fail and he would
fail big and he could never get the
nomination from the Democratic Party for
President Kennedy at that time in there
in the mid-60s was looking in 1972 to
receive the nomination of president of
the Democratic Party now what makes my
book on Robert Kennedy different than
the ones that are already out there are
there's really two different sets of
books one are one set are biographies
that put his psychology and character
under some kind of a microscope the
others are memoirs from people who knew
her worked with Robert Kennedy what I do
in my book is I use primary documents
most of which have never been seen
before
to capture the reader's attention and
bring the reader into the drama of the
social changes that took place in this
country between 1965 and 1968 I
emphasized the centrality of the social
movements of the period which lobbying
Kennedy hard for years to take ever
tougher stands against the war in
Vietnam and against poverty and racism
at home Kennedy was in a constant
dialogue with the most important social
organizations
and individual leaders of the mid-60s
including leaders of the National
Committee to end the war in Vietnam
clergy and laity concerned about Vietnam
Vietnam Benjamin Spock Tom Hayden
John Kenneth Galbraith the Cornell
professor George can who probably knew
more about Vietnam than anybody else in
the United States at the time and gave
me an access to his personal papers and
read my chapters on Vietnam Robert
Kennedy was in a dialogue with
representatives of the more militant
african-american groups united
farmworker activists and thousands of
ordinary citizens who were then meeting
in union halls churches and in their
homes printing handbills and canvassing
door-to-door against the war in Vietnam
all of these groups and individuals use
the combination of moral suasion and
rational argument to push Kennedy in
their direction and after hesitating
mainly for fear of splitting the
Democratic Party at a time when landmark
liberal legislation was being passed as
well as not wishing to destroy his own
political future he decided to cash in
all of his political chips in 1968 and
challenged Johnson directly for the
Democratic presidential nomination in my
two chapters where I discussed the
political struggles within the
Democratic Party entitled at the center
of the storm and the hottest place in
hell I kept you the sense of
disappointment among Kennedy's anti-war
supporters but I also placed Kennedy's
political predicament in its context
facing the awesome might of Lyndon
Johnson who had held most of the
important political cards Kennedy
himself was anguished by his predicament
he felt boxed in the social movements
pulling him in one direction the
Democratic Party leadership which
supported the Vietnam War in the
opposite direction to his credit Robert
Kennedy did break free from these
constraints but he had to wait for the
peace movement to grow in size and
momentum to give him the political
leverage to take on Lyndon John
the peace movement successfully put
pressure on many Democratic
congressional delegations particularly
in California New York New England and a
few other states such as Minnesota where
Eugene McCarthy and Hubert Humphrey were
from and Wisconsin which had one of the
nation's most important activist
colleges and Madison african-americans
who supported Robert Kennedy and
enormous numbers were also mobilized
after ten years of civil rights
struggles robbery of Kennedy and Martin
Luther King jr. voice similar criticisms
about the disproportionate number of
African Americans being killed in
Vietnam in relation to their numbers in
the population the disparities in black
and white unemployment rates which both
Kennedy and King saw as a major social
cause of the urban rebellions in watts
Detroit and elsewhere the widespread
practice of redlining african-american
communities in a certain impoverished
areas of America's largest cities the
unfair and high prices paid by
african-americans and urban centers for
shoddy municipal services and rents the
slumlords the all-white police forces in
black areas and the incidence of police
brutality which lit the spark of the
riots in watts and in Detroit and in
Newark and elsewhere Los Angeles Mayor
Sam Yorty appro Johnson Democrat
denounced both Kennedy and King for
coming to watts in the wake of the Watts
riot which broke out in August 1965 and
King and Kennedy emphasized the social
causes of the unrest King left and
discussed
he said the white leadership of Los
Angeles displayed a blind intransigence
and ignorance of the tremendous social
forces which are at work here Kennedy
said after touring watts in the wake of
the riot it is one thing to assure a man
the legal right to eat in a restaurant
it is another thing to assure he can
earn the money to eat there Kennedy
argued that the riots arose in part from
the government's inability to directly
affect the wide margins between black
and white unemployed
rates I discussed these issues in a
lengthy chapter entitled civil rights in
the urban rebellions chapter 8 in my
book
Martin Kings poor people's campaign
which he announced in December 1967 as
an alternative to the riots that broke
out in Detroit in Newark in the summer
of 67 sought to bring 300 thousand of
the nation's poor people to Washington
DC to camp out until a 30 billion dollar
domestic Marshall Plan was enacted by
Congress this mobilization of the
nation's poor coincided with Kennedy's
uphill struggle for the presidential
nomination and would help him
politically King and Kennedy were
informal allies the march on Washington
the King had been organizing at the time
of his assassination scared the hell out
of official Washington they weren't
looking forward to this King wanted to
wanted it to be bigger than the 1963
August march on Washington but it was
the war in Vietnam that divided the
Democratic Party and forced Kennedy to
abandon his plans to wait and seek the
presidential nomination in 1972 and
instead make a bid against Johnson in 68
now I'd like to say a few words about
Kennedy and the Vietnam War I think
there has been a mischaracterization
often of Robert Kennedy's views of
Vietnam War in some publications that
claim that he basically supported the
war until it became a political
liability for Johnson and then he
decided to challenge Johnson I'd like to
say and I cover these in the first two
chapters of my book although back in
1962 when when Robert Kennedy was
Attorney General and president john f
kennedy's key advisor he did support the
government of south vietnam and he did
support the anti-communist struggle in
vietnam but in 1965 is the junior
senator from new york when lyndon
johnson began to bomb North Vietnam
and escalate the number of US troops in
a big way
Kennedy consistently disagreed with
Johnson's policy in Southeast Asia
Kennedy never supported the bombing of
North Vietnam and he never supported the
introduction of American ground troops
into Vietnam he opposed the
Americanization of the conflict on may 6
1965 Kennedy said quote I do not believe
we should be under the self delusion
that this military effort will bring Ho
Chi Minh or the Vietcong to their knees
from 1965 through 1967 Kennedy denounced
the bombing of North Vietnam whenever
Johnson offered a bombing pause as he
did in December 1965 Kennedy called for
its extension and then issued statements
of regret whenever Johnson decided to
resume bombing you might be surprised to
hear this but in 1964 in 1965 in 1966
Lyndon Johnson's popularity increased
whenever he bombed North Vietnam there
was a martial spirit in this country the
country was divided and polarized in the
Vietnam War Johnson said the bombing of
North Vietnam kept led out of our boys
bellies in December 1965 Kennedy
advocated an end to the bombing and a
ceasefire to quote provide an avenue by
which the conflict can be brought from
the battlefield to the conference table
when Johnson resumed bombing in January
66 Kennedy said it is not our war
obviously the resumption of bombing in
the north is not a policy and we should
not delude ourselves that it offers a
painless method of winning the war for
if we regard bombing as the answer in
Vietnam we are headed straight for
disaster On February 19 1966 Kennedy
went out on a limb and called for the
United States to formally recognize the
National Liberation Front in South
Vietnam
he said the NLF was at the heart of the
hope for a negotiated
it may mean a compromise government
fully acceptable to neither side but we
must be willing to face the
uncertainties of election and the
possibility of an eventual vote on
reunification the United States Kennedy
went on had to give some reason for the
Vietcong to come to the conference table
or be prepared for a long and bloody
fight which eventually may bring in
China now I also have to say that George
can the Cornell professor Southeast
Asian isnora sponding with Robert
Kennedy this time had been pointing to
the NLF as the key problem in South
Vietnam the National Liberation Front
was an umbrella organization which
included non-communist nationalist
Buddhists civil servants students and
other elements in South Vietnamese
society that any Saigon government
needed politically to survive what
Robert Kennedy was pointing to by saying
we should recognize the NLF for the
United States should recognize the
Anaheim was the Achilles heel of the
entire war in Vietnam that this group
that the United States called the
Vietcong could not be crushed militarily
that it had to be negotiated with
politically there was an extremely
hostile reaction in the news media and
from the Johnson administration to
Kennedy's call to recognize the NLF
under Secretary of State George ball who
privately shared many of Kennedy's
dovish views and had been an advisor to
John F Kennedy publicly called Kennedy's
suggestion impossible and absurd
on the television show issues and
answers National Security Advisor
McGeorge Bundy denounced Kennedy's
proposal as useless on Meet the Press
vice president Hubert Humphrey like in
Kennedy's call to include the NLF in a
political settlement in South Vietnam to
having a fox in the chicken coop or an
arsonist in the fire department I do not
believe we should write a prescription
for Vietnam which includes a dose of
arsenic Humphrey Sen
headlines across the country read quote
RFK wants via treads and coalition and
the Chicago Tribune ran the story of
Kennedy's press conference under the
simple headline hochi Kennedy Kennedy
clearly lost the media battle with the
administration over recognizing the NLF
and the peace movement in February 1966
in this country was not then strong
enough to back him up under the Johnson
administration's pressure and Kennedy
retreated I cover most of this in
Chapter 1 of the book in April 1966
behind the scenes without public fanfare
Kennedy privately urged the State
Department to secretly negotiate with
the NLF for the release of 27 American
POWs it held in South Vietnam the State
Department flatly rejected Kennedy's
proposals these were some of the
documents that have never been seen
before that I uncovered at the Kennedy
Library the State Department rejected it
because it would require a degree of
official recognition of the NLF the
Johnson administration was unwilling to
give the NLF had offered to exchange
American boys for Vietnamese prisoners
that were held by the Saigon regime
later that month Kennedy pointed out
publicly which also reflected Georges
cane and other Southeast Asian scholars
views quote there is still great
political instability in South Vietnam
and South Vietnam is where the war is
being fought without a viable political
structure in South Vietnam the efforts
and sacrifice of our fighting men will
be wasted but no military action in
North Vietnam or China
can create or contribute to the creation
of such a political structure in South
Vietnam so Kennedy even after being
publicly burned for advocating
recognition of the NLF continued to
point to the Achilles heel of the entire
US war effort in Vietnam the political
ineptitude corruption weakness
and brutality of the us-backed Saigon
government Kennedy also said quote every
detached observer has testified to the
enormous corruption which pervades every
level of South Vietnamese official life
in February 1967 Kennedy traveled to
Europe which was called in confidential
Johnson White House memos Bobby's royal
trip to Europe contemptuously and he
gauged the extent of the Western Allies
disagreement with the US war in Vietnam
Hanoi offered Kennedy what the media
called a peace feeler which is too
complicated to go in to right now it's a
chapter to my book but upon his return
of the United States
Kennedy was portrayed as usurping the
president's prerogative and foreign
affairs in a private meeting with
Johnson a pran upon his return in the
White House Johnson told Robert F
Kennedy quote you doves will be dead in
six months he meant politically you're
it's over Johnson was confident that the
enemy had met his master in the field so
on March 2nd 1967 Kennedy gave what was
then known as his stop the bombing
speech he calls for removing the United
States as a unilateral force in Vietnam
I'll just read his little segment of the
speech kennedy said an international
group should be asked to inspect the
borders and ports of the country to
report any further escalation and under
the direction of the United Nations and
with an international presence gradually
replacing American forces we should move
toward a final settlement which allows
the major political elements in South
Vietnam to participate in the choice of
leadership and shape their direction as
a people again pointing to the umbrella
organization of the National Liberation
Front yet despite Kennedy's consistent
criticisms of the war he would not break
with Lyndon Johnson and continue to
endorse his re-election
out of party loyalty and support of
Johnson's domestic agenda also the
insurgent dove wing of the party was
still not strong enough to take on the
incumbent Johnson who controlled all of
the levers of power of the presidency
and the Democratic National Committee
Johnson also had the solid support of
George Meany of the afl-cio
the nation's largest labor union and the
support of Roy Wilkins and the
n-double-a-cp
and other mainstream civil rights groups
because of Johnson's landmark civil
rights legislation on June 3rd 1967 at a
democratic fundraiser in Manhattan
Kennedy introduced Lyndon Johnson
sandwiched between the president and
vice president Hubert Humphrey he called
Johnson a quote-unquote great leader and
said he would support Johnson's
re-election in 1968 Kennedy's cozying to
Johnson reinforced the notion held by
his critics from the peace movement that
political expediency would always
supersede Kennedy's moral opposition to
the war I cover this wavering on
Kennedy's part in my chapter called the
hottest place in hell this was a
paraphrase of Dante that John Kennedy
and Robert Kennedy were fond of quoting
that stated that the hottest places in
hell where we reserved for those who in
times of moral crisis maintain their
neutrality his critique of the war grew
in moral outrage yet he still officially
endorsed Johnson the peace movement grew
in leaps and bounds by November 1967 and
Minnesota senator Eugene McCarthy
affixed his name to Allard Lowenstein's
movement to dump Johnson which was from
the campuses that same month Robert
Kennedy said this we're killing South
Vietnamese we're killing children we're
killing women we're killing innocent
people because we don't want to have the
war fought on American soil or because
there are 12,000 miles away and they
might get to be 11,000
miles away in the same interview Kennedy
pointed out that there were 35,000
people without limbs in South Vietnam
and a hundred and fifty thousand
civilian casualties every year by the
end of 1967 the peace movement which
organized giant demonstrations at the
Pentagon in October and to stop the
draft week organizing had opened up the
debate on the war so Kennedy could voice
his opposition in stronger terms and I
also wanted to point out that Martin
Luther King jr. did not break with
Johnson on the war in Vietnam until
April 1967 a month after Kennedy stopped
the bombing address and when Martin
Luther King broke with Johnson on the
war in April 1967 the leadership of the
n-double a-c-p & Whitney not young of
the Urban League and Johnson
administration civil rights allies all
attacked King for coming out against the
war the n-double-a-cp went so far as to
pass a resolution denouncing any attempt
to link the anti-war movement with the
civil rights movement King believed this
was a mistake
throughout 1967 Kennedy agonized over
what to do politically to stop the war
in Vietnam he attempted to differentiate
between the courage of his convictions
and political self-destruction he was
too much of a pragmatist too tilted
windmills and he would not take on
Johnson unless he had his political
ducks lined in a row one month before
Eugene McCarthy strong showing in the
New Hampshire primary
Kennedy assessed the meaning of the Tet
Offensive that had broken out in
virtually every town and city in South
Vietnam at the end of January 1968 the
turning point of the Vietnam War in a
chapter called the collapse of the myths
I described the key events associated
with the Tet Offensive and in another
chapter called the breaking point I show
that it was Kennedy's interpretation of
the Tet Offensive that led him to decide
to challenge Johnson in the remaining
presidential primaries
On February 8th 1968 in a watershed
speech in Chicago with Mayor Richard
Daley by his side the king maker who
would host the Democratic National
Convention that August Kennedy said it
was time for the truth about the Vietnam
War and he exposed what he called the
illusions upon which the war was based
the Johnson administration claimed that
the Tet Offensive was an unmitigated
United States military victory Kennedy
disagreed saying it was a major defeat
indicating that the administration had
quote misconceived the nature of the war
people will not fight to line the
pockets of generals or swell the bank
accounts of the wealthy Kennedy said and
of the Saigon regime he said this we
have an ally in name only we support a
government without supporters without
the efforts of American arms that
government would not last a day this
last point is key because Kennedy
publicly concluded that the Saigon
government was a creation of the United
States when most of the mainstream press
and the Johnson administration still
would not admit this although Hanoi had
been saying this for years and later
with the publication of the Pentagon
Papers in 1971 leaked by Daniel Ellsberg
it was confirmed with documentary
evidence from the Defense Department in
the same speech Kennedy said the
following for 20 years first the French
and then the United States have been
predicting victory in Vietnam in 1961 in
1962 as well as in 1966 and 1967 we have
been told that the tide is turning there
is light at the end of the tunnel we
could soon bring home the troops victory
is near the enemy is tiring once in 1962
I participated in such predictions
myself but for 20 years we have been
wrong
the history of conflict among nations
does not record another such lengthy and
consistent chronicle of error Robert
Kennedy concluded on February 8th 1968
with Mayor Richard Daley by his side
Kennedy I offered three Mia culpa for
his support of the Saigon regime dating
back to 1962 in his March 1967 stopped
the bombing speech he admitted he had
been wrong in to seek a newer world
which was published in November of 1967
his book of essays he admitted he had
been wrong in 62 and on February 8th
when he assessed the meaning of the Tet
Offensive
he admitted he had been wrong in 1962
but Lyndon Johnson never admitted he had
been wrong about Vietnam read his
memoirs and you'll see so on March 16
1968 the same day as the me Lai massacre
in Vietnam which was not exposed until
20 months later Kennedy entered the
remaining presidential primaries and
finally took on Johnson directly it was
the peace movement in this country that
gave him the political leverage to do so
the country was bitterly divided on the
Vietnam War there is a mythology about
the 1960s in this country and that is
that everybody was out singing songs
about flower power and protesting the
war and sitting in and and having free
love and everything else but the that's
also you have to realize that in the 65
to 68 period Ronald Reagan won his first
elective office in California the
governorship George Wallace the
segregationist Alabama governor formed
his American independent party and ran
113 percent of the vote in 1968 and
Richard Nixon announced that he was
going to seek the presidential
nomination in the Republican Party and
eventually he won so the 60s was a
period of polarization
Division Robert Kennedy said repeatedly
in public that a Nixon presidency would
be quote unacceptable to the country
unquote on March 18th 1968 two days
after Kennedy announced his candidacy at
Kansas State University John Kennedy
called Johnson's Vietnam policy bankrupt
and deeply wrong the administration's
only response to failure Kennedy said
had been to repeat it on a larger scale
I am concerned that at the end of it all
there will only be more Americans killed
more of our treasures spilled out and
because of the bitterness and hatred on
every side in this war more hundreds of
thousands of Vietnamese slaughtered so
that they may say as Tacitus said of
Rome they made a desert and called it
peace now let me say a few words about
the political campaign thus began an
epic struggle over the heart and soul of
the Democratic Party
Kennedy sought to galvanize the social
movements of the period including the
peace movement the maturing civil rights
movement as evidenced by Martin Luther
King's Poor People's Campaign the Latino
farm worker movement headed by Cesar
Chavez anti-war clergy youth students
workers and others into a viable
coalition that could unseat the pro
Vietnam War Democratic Party leadership
it was a big gamble the Johnson and
Humphrey forces controlled the
administration most of the missed
municipal political machines the
leadership of the afl-cio CIO and then
double ACP in the urban league as I
mentioned before the Democratic National
Committee the FBI most of the political
press and commentators such as Drew
Pearson and Joseph Olson the news media
loved the horse race angle of the
struggle between Kennedy and Johnson and
between McCarthy and Humphrey and
Kennedy later and often ignored what the
peace candidate alternatives were saying
about the war in Vietnam
at a time when more Americans were dying
in Vietnam than any other time in during
the entire war far more interesting than
the personality cult around Robert
Kennedy where the forces within the
Democratic Party he represented and what
he was saying about the Vietnam War race
relations and American society generally
with regard to his battle with the other
peace candidate Eugene McCarthy I'd like
to say a couple of things too I cover
this in a few chapters actually in the
book building a coalition as a title of
Horniman
Eugene McCarthy the senator from
Minnesota who was a peace candidate who
had a campus back in a pretty thin
political base compared to Kennedy's
announced on November 30th 1967 that he
was going to run as a peace candidate
alternative to Lyndon Johnson but he
also said two weeks later quote it's
nonsense to set my mind on the
presidency the challenge is on the issue
that's the important thing I'm testing
the system everybody knew that Lyndon
Johnson would crush Eugene McCarthy at
the convention and that Eugene McCarthy
had no chance of winning the nomination
Robert Kennedy on the other hand with
his base among white working-class
african-americans Latinos especially in
California where Cesar Chavez suspended
the boycott suspended the the the strike
in California and sent out all his
organizers the campaign for Kennedy in
California that Robert Kennedy had the
money the organization the contacts and
the mass base to make a credible move
against Johnson and then Humphrey for
the Democratic nomination for president
in 1968
unlike Eugene McCarthy Kennedy spoke
after winning the 174 delegate votes in
the California primary on June 4th 1968
in the Ambassador Hotel in his final
speech he spoke to McCarthy supporters
and here's what he said to those who
have supported Senator McCarthy
I have only this to say you have fought
well for principles in which you
believed in my judgment I now remain the
only candidate who can be nominated who
is also in substantial agreement with
those principles in particular I am the
only candidate committed to a realistic
negotiated solution to the Vietnamese
War one embracing all the elements of
the South Vietnamese population in fact
I am the only candidate with policies
likely to bring an honorable peace to
let the killing stop
now I wanted to give you I've been
reading a lot of Kennedy's quotes and
quotes from King and others and I wanted
to give you just a slight flavor of my
own voice as an author at the end of the
book in chapter 10 I'll read what I
wrote
following Kennedy's last words my thanks
to all of you and on to Chicago the
laughter music and sharing blended into
an enormous final ovation Kennedy
flashed a quick V for victory gesture
with his right hand brushed back his
forelock stepped from the podium and
started out slowly through the crushing
throng toward an exit on his left he was
led down a cramped narrow pathway
through the hotel kitchen at the
opposite end was a door that opened to a
room where a post victory press
conference had been arranged the kitchen
was packed with over 70 campaign workers
celebrants reporters and hotel employees
as Kennedy made his way through the
pantry he shook hands with food service
workers and signed a few autographs
there was a sudden burst of commotion to
the right of the senator those around
him quickly realized someone was
discharging a weapon it was a 22 caliber
handgun Kennedy was shot just behind his
right ear five others were wounded the
assailant a disturbed 24 year old
Jordanian immigrant had fired a $30 Iver
Johnson pistol with his California
victory Kennedy was on his way to
winning the Democratic Party's
nomination for president he had worked
harder and longer hours than anyone else
on the campaign he deserved a rewarding
meaningful night of relaxation and
celebration instead he found himself
collapsed on the greasy concrete floor
of the Ambassador hotels kitchen pantry
some of Kennedy's insights about
American society are as relevant today
as they were thirty years ago in March
1968 he pointed out to an audience in
Des Moines Iowa that the economic
yardstick of the gross national product
counts air pollution and cigarette
advertising and ambulances to clear our
streets of carnage it counts the special
locks for our doors and jails for the
people who break them it counts the
destruction of our redwoods and the loss
of natural wonder to chaotic sprawl it
counts napalm and nuclear warheads and
armored cars for the police to fight
riots in our cities it counts Whitman's
rifle and specks knife and television
programs which glorify violence to sell
toys to our children two months later
the 42 year old senator and presidential
candidate said in my judgment it is
imperative that we less than the Gulf
which divides those who have and those
who do not I do not believe our nation
can survive unless we are able to
accomplish a change which brings with it
an acceptable life for all if one
segment of our society is impoverished
it impoverishes us all thank you
okay so now let's have some questions
question answer period what we have a
mic up here so don't be shy let's uh
let's have some come on I'm gonna I'm
gonna continue this out here we go we
have a question I just started reading
your book by the way I've been enjoying
it looking forward to finishing it poses
oh yeah good well you can hear me you
could use I think you could use this one
to the events birth that's for the video
but that's for the room I believe okay I
think I like I said I've been enjoying
the book I'm looking forward to
finishing it I'm wondering after you did
all this research it's not all positive
about Robert Kennedy for example when he
was supporting Lyndon Johnson when
clearly he was not really very happy
with him how do you feel about Robert
Kennedy as a person after writing this
book well that's a very that's a very
good question I thank you for that I
think that what's what's interesting I
think about as a person is when Robert
Kennedy answered questions as a human
being he often got he was attacked in
the media there I'll give you a couple
of examples one was he was at USC in
November of 1965 and some students asked
him well you know what do you think
about draft resistance and he said well
I wouldn't necessarily choose that route
myself he was just answering as a as a
person you know but if people want to
resist the draft and they're willing to
accept the consequences
then he supported their right to dissent
and that and the media kind of jumped on
him for advocating draft-dodging for
that which was it was a very human
response and in that same interview is
interesting too is that the students at
us
they asked him there were there were a
lot of they called it collateral damage
then - and there were all sorts of
Vietnamese civilians in North Vietnam
when Johnson was bombing North Vietnam
that were being injured and they needed
blood in North Vietnam and he was asked
if there was extra blood in South
Vietnam would you approve of blood going
to civilians in North Vietnam who were
victimized by the war and he again he
answered as a human being as a
compassionate person just he said yes I
think blood should go to anybody who
needs it and then the media attacked him
for that they said that he was
advocating sending blood to the Vietcong
and and they had the Sen rejoinders
disclaimers you know for years have a
constituents were angry alabama Governor
George Wallace referred to Kennedy
publicly as that guy who advocated
sending blood to the Vietcong you know I
mean but he was just answering questions
as a human being I think what's
interesting about Robert Kennedy is I
think politicians today are so guarded
and and the sound bites are so short
that you never get to see a human being
anymore and he often showed I think that
was one of his most appealing
characteristics is that he showed that
he would answer a question honestly he
would answer a question as a human being
he would go and have confrontations with
groups like in Oakland he did with a
black caucus where for an hour they got
up there and they just ridiculed him for
being not radical enough you know and he
sat and he listened and he had a
dialogue with groups that were far to
his left and he was very bloodied his
hand in ten his hands in ten our
motorcades and he you know he was really
out there and I think that what what I
what I was struck with Robert Kennedy as
a person is I think that he he wanted to
play his political cards intelligently
but he was also I think an interesting
human being and that's one of the
reasons why you had a lot of fluff
pieces about the
be family about him and his families the
interesting person but I think that that
he was a rare breed of politician who it
reminds me of I don't think there's been
a politician since in the last 30 years
who could as this picture these are
photographs from the book that I have
here that he could in March of 68 break
a fast with Cesar Chavez who represented
the campesinos in California the
lowest-paid most oppressed workers in
America where the the National Labor
Relations Act didn't even apply to them
he could break a fast with Cesar Chavez
and then he could go to Chicago and
light a cigar and talk hardball politics
with the likes of Mayor Richard Daley
the kingmaker and Robert Kennedy his
ability to embrace the social movements
of the period and to also play hardball
with the municipal bosses and the
political power brokers of the period I
think make him a unique political
phenomenon that we also we haven't seen
that much in the years since to but but
to answer your question I think that he
he wanted to do the right thing he
wanted to end the killing in Vietnam he
wanted to build a more just society in
America and I think that he he also
understood that he had to take certain
pragmatic steps to get there he was
sincere I think he was that I think he
was definitely some stupid in supporting
Johnson the first time well that's a cop
see it's a complicated story that I
cover in these two chapters and well you
have to read a bit but I think Robert
Kennedy was in the hottest place in hell
there for a while
in 67 he he wanted to do all he could to
end the war in Vietnam but he didn't
want to ruin his chances to to win the
presidential nomination in 1970
you have to realize he was only 42 years
old when he was killed
and he could have had a long career in
fact if he had he could still be sitting
in the Senate right now in the seat that
Hillary Clinton has now but I mean you
know Edward Kennedy is still there so
unfortunately he the the title of my
conclusion is a potential unrealized we
will really never know what what kind of
impact he he could have made on the
country but I do believe he was a rare
breed and politician in that he had a
faith in the American people
to make the right choices at pivotal
moments actually spoken to a couple of
your former students who said you were a
fantastic teacher and just wondering
where we could look forward to seeing
you teaching next well oh great I hope
so I'm looking for a tenure track job
right now actually and it's eluded me
and I might be teaching at Cornell next
fall but I also might be teaching on the
West Coast I'm not sure yet thank you
thank you
hi Joe I'd like to know what your
thoughts are about what you think Robert
Kennedy's influences on today's politics
or legacy it doesn't let didn't last or
did it really die with him I mean he had
a powerful coalition going on and there
was so much hope
back then in that era and when King died
and then he died it just like seemed
like something was sucked out of thee
that whole movement and the hope and
like you said politicians now or you
know talking sound bites and don't see
me honest or direct enough and I feel
that rubber kennedy is often
overshadowed by JFK like me can you talk
a little bit about that yeah sure that's
a great question I I think that what I
when I started to write this book I was
writing a book about the social
movements of the 60s and Robert
Kennedy's role and then it also ended up
becoming a book about really the
unraveling of the New Deal coalition in
a lot of ways and the the kind of
destruction of the Democratic Party I
think the Democratic Party since 1968
has had a prolonged identity crisis in
my own my own opinion to bring it to
just to give you some examples is that
with the assassination of Robert Kennedy
what happened at the Chicago Convention
in August that August was an absolute
disaster where it reflected Robert
Kennedy's absence from that from that
convention in other words instead of
Robert Kennedy marching into that
convention with he had influence but
about of about 700 delegates you see to
be more specific about the 68 period was
you needed thirteen hundred and twelve
delegate votes to win the nomination for
president and and a lot of the political
commentators at the time were saying
that well Hubert Humphrey is going to
win it but Hubert Humphrey really didn't
have three
he didn't have a lock on thirteen
hundred and twelve delegates and after
Kennedy won the 174 delegate votes in
California he had one about 63 in
Indiana he won twenty-something in
Nebraska he went South Dakota you wanted
DC he lost an Oregon to Eugene McCarthy
but Robert Kennedy was going to pick up
McCarthy's delegates more sooner or
later he probably would go into the
Democratic National Convention in August
of 1968 with with about seven hundred
delegates and all he really needed to do
is play hardball with Daley who I who I
believe he Kennedy had daily for various
reasons you have to read the book but he
was going to go all he had to do is
block Humphrey on the first ballot at
the convention and then Humphreys
position probably would have eroded with
each subsequent ballot the way the
conventions worked then and Robert
Kennedy probably would have won the
nomination for president instead we had
a dispirited the the dailies police beat
the protesters outside the Democratic
convention you've seen the film of it
probably there are shoving matches among
the delegates of the Democrats inside
the convention hall it was a terrible
disaster for the Democratic Party and
the the party was dispirited as a went
into the November elections what
happened was you had Richard Nixon win
in 1968 okay so after all of those
social movements after the Kings the
Southern Christian Leadership Conference
Dartmouth back in Montgomery you know
Alabama the bus boycott and 55 and 56
going all the way to 68 King was
assassinated in April 4th 1968 a tweet
which killed the the Poor People's
Campaign forget was over at that point
and then Robert Kennedy was killed right
after he won the biggest primary most
important primary election that season
in California and that took the wind out
of the the peace movements electoral you
know sales going into the convention so
what happens is disaster in Chicago and
then you had Richard Nixon win in 68
and from 1968 you had a quarter century
of Republican domination of the White
House except for Jimmy Carter's one term
and Jimmy Carter is not really
considered one of the great presidents
of American history I mean he's a great
former president I love him
you know Habitat for Humanity and his
peace initiatives but the Democratic
Party I think there was a struggle for
the soul of the Democratic Party in that
period that's 65 to 68 period there were
two Democratic parties there was one
Democratic Party that swirled around the
social movements of the period the
maturing african-american struggle the
anti-poverty movement Latino farmworkers
the peace movement youth students and
then the other part of the Democratic
Party which revolved around that
southern segregationist wing of that
Democratic Party and kind of Lyndon
Johnson's pro-war senators Hubert
Humphrey and Henry scoop Jackson the
senator from Washington State who
chaired the Armed Services Committee
they were committed Hawks in Vietnam and
that Vietnam War was a bipartisan
warrant but it was the Democrats
controlled the administration they
controlled the house and they controlled
the Senate and so the divisions caused
by that debt by that Vietnam War it tore
the Democratic Party apart and I believe
the Democratic Party has had an identity
crisis ever since that period in my
opinion I I think that what you see in
the 65 to 68 period is a dominant
political party with a one sturdy
coalition that FDR had passed behind
that was that Lyndon Johnson had built
on with with these very important
programs the Civil Rights Act the Voting
Rights Act you know Medicare Medicaid
etc and it all kind of came crashing
down under the weight of the
contradictions of what you might call
Cold War liberalism what I would call
cold
liberalism in other words the the
hypocrisy of trying to build a more just
society at home for your citizens while
you're dropping seven million tons of
bombs on a small country in Southeast
Asia and that was a contradiction that
the peace movement pointed out and the
peace movement was lobbying that the
Democratic Party most of the Republicans
Gerald Ford and the Holga Nixon the
whole gang most Republicans with a few
notable exceptions their only critique
of the Vietnam War was that Johnson
wasn't bombing enough any what he didn't
sufficiently unleash the military enough
because Johnson was showing some
restraint about bombing Hanoi and
Haiphong so I hope that answers your
question I don't know if thank you
I know this is hardly the focus of your
book but I've just curious that because
I know less about it than others at the
time his assassination you gave us that
one line about who had killed him I
don't really know much of anything about
his assassin it was sort of curious if
you knew you know what motivated him to
do it I know he was about that Kennedy
was a radical figure at the time and had
you know plenty of reasons to have
enemies but the the just the description
you gave of the guy made him seem sort
of an odd one to to have actually
carried out the the assassination I do
do discuss a metal on the book or the
reason behind his assassination well
that's it I mean that's a very
interesting point good question I
purposely I wanted this book to be about
Robert Kennedy's life and not his death
there are there are books that focus
primarily on the assassination and the
investigation that took place afterwards
by the special unit senator by a unit
that was formed by the Los Angeles
Police Department and and the motives of
the assassin sirhan sirhan
I purposely did not Sirhan Sirhan's name
that does not appear in my book I
purposely made that choice because I
wanted to speak about Robert Kennedy's
life just as James Earl Ray the man who
allegedly killed Martin Luther King his
name doesn't appear in my book either
but the case is interesting because mr.
hung
he was found with my understanding $400
in cash in his pocket no ID and a
clipping of a speech that Robert Kennedy
had given to a Jewish group in LA Robert
Kennedy of course was a strong supporter
of Israel as was Richard Nixon and all
the other candidates for president that
year but the motive for the actual
killing of Robert Kennedy that they that
has been officially attributed to sir
Hahn who I think was an insane person I
don't know if a motive really can be
attributed to Sirhan
but the motive was has been officially
kind of told as it's because Kennedy
supported Israel but sir Han could have
easily just as easily have shot Richard
Nixon or anybody other candidates
because they all supported Israel so I
don't know I mean Kennedy was outspoken
supporter of of Israel and it was a very
tough period you know the six-day war in
67 and all that and so was a volatile
time for Middle Eastern politics as well
and the I wasn't concerned with the
motive now you know the question that's
a very good question what I tried to do
in all honesty when I was moving through
those documents at the Kennedy Library
and I was going through the Kennedy's
presidential campaign papers boxes and
boxes and boxes of documents you get
this impression of this bandwagon is
just moving I mean Hollywood celebrities
Elizabeth Taylor and Warren Beatty and
Shirley MacLaine everybody is just
coming out and they're all there's just
supporting Robert Kennedy and this this
thing has really got legs and it's
really moving and it's really exciting
and then all of a sudden Robert Kennedy
is assassinated and he's removed from
this and and I when I was I remember
that day sitting in the Kennedy Library
in Boston and feeling the sense that
it's over now and all of that activity
was it was as if Kennedy we're at the
hub of a great wheel of social forces
that had lost its bearings he was the
center figure I mean there were groups
that hated each other that might not get
along like for instance Irish carpenter
unions in South Boston you know and
african-americans in the south side of
Chicago who might not get along normally
but they both would agree they both
supported Robert Kennedy somehow you
know it was very interesting you don't
see that very often in Gary Indiana a
city that had a terrible racial problems
between blacks and whites when he went
through Gary Anna he was able to bring
together African
Americans and whites in such a way and
so it's it was a very exciting campaign
his primary campaigns but it was a very
dangerous campaign to I should say that
there was a motorcade in Lansing
Michigan where a man was spotted with a
rifle on a roof and they kept Kennedy
and in a garage before they left and
they wouldn't tell him why and then
finally they went off and then when they
said well we we held up the motorcade
because we saw somebody with a rifle on
a roof and Robert Kennedy was livid he
was very angry so never stopped one of
my motorcades I don't care what you see
anywhere I mean he he didn't have any
security there there was a bomb threat
in Satellite Salt Lake City there were
somebody there was an assault in Oregon
on camping he was out there just as
Martin Luther King was they were out
there and they were sitting ducks I mean
they were Lyndon Johnson after Robert
Kennedy was assassinated ordered Secret
Service protection for presidential
candidates but Robert Kennedy for all
intents and purposes was just out there
and there's so many guns in this society
and there were so many guns than in this
society that it it could have happened
at any time take more time that I
deserve but why did what do you think he
was so defined against protection in the
in the environment that he was it at the
time considering that you know he was
the family member was just killed
recently the same sort of well you know
it I mean I have one of one of the
photos here actually it's it's here I
don't know if I don't know if you could
see very well with the video there might
be some glare but this is a motorcade in
watts that he was on and he was going up
and down in motorcades all over the
place during this campaign with no
security at all and we all know his his
brother was assassinated
you know from a high-powered rifle so
I'm not sure he was um courageous is the
only I think that we live in a time now
where we in the year 2001 with the
violence in American society which we
take for granted I think we assume that
that this would be considered reckless
today you know but I think the 60s again
back then there was a little bit more
naivete about American society there was
shock and anger when Martin Luther King
was assassinated although he had death
threats for for 10 years and Robert
Kennedy had his share of death threats
too and the the final point I would make
is that Martin Luther King was 39 when
he was assassinated Robert Kennedy was
42 and John Kennedy was only 46 when
they are assassinated and this country
we had three of the most important
leaders of the 1960s all gunned down
violently and we've still produced in my
2.5 million handguns a year and sold in
the market and Messiah t-that lost three
of its most important young leaders
three decades ago to gun violence would
have some kind of control over this kind
of gun access to guns but thank you for
the question
you bet you
the other the video mics over here too
but the other might yeah that's the
romance with you I'd like to commend you
for your incredible research and the
insights you the insight you brought to
bear on your book respect to Kennedy but
I do have a question and you don't mind
if I ask a friend of mine some tough
questions you did I think a commendable
job in dispelling the level which has
been put around respect to Kennedy
RFK saying that he's an uppity was an
opportunist that if if Eugene McCarthy
hadn't don't quite well in the New
Hampshire primary he wouldn't have a
challenge Lyndon Johnson but you were
saying you get your argument you're the
central thrust of your argument is that
Kennedy was waiting for the peace
movement to develop before he decided to
join which in itself doesn't really
dispel totally dispel the level of
opportunism or you were only portraying
him as being a pragmatist but my
question is respect to social movements
if that's if the social movement was a
crystallizing factor modern does social
movement had been there after he was
assassinated to push through to make
sure that a candidate that was amenable
to their philosophy or the abuse respect
to Vietnam end up when in the 1968
election why wasn't that the case that's
the question I wanted to ask and then
the second question I just wanted to you
know respect to relevance can one draw
any parallels between the social
movement then and the personalities or
the issues respect to American
involvement in Vietnam can one draw
parallels with it to say Iraq u.s.
involvement in Iraq or us current
involvement in Colombia respect to Plan
Colombia can one draw any parallels or
what the relevance to contemporary
American as
you know social and you know foreign
policy so you may want to back to those
thank you okay thank you for your
question I I am I I would say that
that's a very good question and it has
to do with this book is a social history
of the 1960s and the social history as
social historians will tell you that
leaders are kind of epiphenomena you
know that they that leaders come and go
but if a social movement has legs and is
strong enough leaders can come go and
that movement will continue forward now
sometimes though leaders are important
and a give you example what happened
it's hard to imagine it when you look at
US history for instance it's hard to
imagine the New Deal taking place in the
30s without Franklin Roosevelt for
instance you know that's one sometimes
leaders are very important and I think
that the 60s I think although there was
a cult of personality around Martin
Luther King and there was a cult of
personality around Kennedy and they were
waiting for he Kennedy was waiting for
these social movements to kind of give
him the political leverage to to move
against Lyndon Johnson what happened was
when Kennedy was taken out I mean
assassination political assassination is
that's the the shocking violent
abruptness of it that was when Eugene
McCarthy for instance that was his
moment maybe in other words somebody
could have come forward and tried to
galvanize those social movements now
what ended up happening was when Robert
Kennedy was assassinated Tom Hayden and
the National Committee to end the war in
Vietnam you know the Mobe and all the
peace groups SDS the student groups they
were organizing these massive
demonstrations to go to Chicago and
lobby at the the Democratic National
Convention now what happened is they
went into the convention and Mayor Daley
and the leadership decided that they
were not going to give
the peace movement even after Eugene
McCarthy's you know strong showing in
New Hampshire his he won the Wisconsin
primary he won the Oregon primary beat
Kennedy Kennedy won Indiana when
Nebraska won South Dakota DC California
and they were then they were peace
candidate alternatives and despite the
movement when they got to the convention
all they wanted all they wanted was the
Democratic Party to insert a plank in
the platform that would tie the the
nominees hands to say that that the
nominee would seek peaceful negotiated
settlement in Vietnam and what they did
at the convention was the leadership
under Humphrey and Johnson behind the
scenes and the pro war faction of the
Democratic Party
they just bowled them over they said no
there was no peace plank in the platform
they got nothing that social movement so
after all of that after the
assassination of Robert Kennedy and the
McCarthy campaign the peace movement in
the United States going into the
Democratic National Convention got
nothing and that's really why the riots
took place outside that convention in in
Chicago I mean they felt so frustrated
so cut out of the loop and it was
disastrous and so Richard Nixon and the
Republicans they could point to the
footage of the Chicago Police beating
you know the demonstrators in the and
the disarray of the of the Chicago
Convention which I think is still the
Democratic Party has still never
recovered from that disastrous
convention that that social movement
needed leadership you know there's a
dialectic I would you know I would put
in a kind of a dialectical arrangement
where social movements need leaders
leaders need social movements there was
a time when I there's a quote from my
book where it's about a European
revolution
marry a leader who looks out the window
and he see he says it's as little
anecdote he says oh well there go the
people I must catch up with them for I
am their leader you know the people were
ahead of Kennedy for a while and then he
caught up with them and he became their
leader and and there was a galvanization
of them they needed to be brought into
the electoral politics of American
society in order to kind of
institutionalize those gains you know
and the Democratic Party in our in our
duopoly you know we have just these two
parties the Democratic Party was really
the only institution that the peace
movement could could put pressure on and
unfortunately Eugene McCarthy I think in
my opinion could have done a much better
job in the wake of the assassination of
Robert Kennedy to try to galvanize those
peace forces and bring them into the
convention in a stronger way than he did
he dropped the ball he fumbled the ball
I think I think I think that they might
have been able to get a piece plank had
McCarthy been Eugene McCarthy been the
leader that he would have been portrayed
to be this this courageous Minnesota
senator who was taking on Johnson when
Kennedy was afraid to I think he really
dropped the ball going into the
Democratic convention now in the
conclusion I talked a little bit about
that about the disastrous convention in
Chicago and I try not to draw too many
speculate too much to draw too many
parallels from that because we don't
know what would have what would have
transpired well what we do know is that
Richard Nixon won the 1968 election
that's what we do now and Richard Nixon
probably shouldn't have won that 1968
election because all he had to offer
really were vague platitudes about how
he had a secret plan to end the war in
Vietnam and then he ended up continuing
the war even expanding it in the
and 20,000 Americans died in Vietnam
under the administration of Richard
Nixon so he didn't wrap up that war very
quickly and I'm I'm I can't speculate
about what could have been or would have
been but the social movement needed
leaders now they answer your other
question which is also very difficult
and and speculative I would say that the
the United States in Vietnam and the
Vietnam period should have followed what
Robert Kennedy had been pointing to
beginning in February of 1966 which was
to have some kind of a recognition of
the National Liberation Front and bring
elements of the National Liberation
Front the non-communist nationalists
that were in South Vietnam bring them
into some kind of a coalition with the
us-backed government in Saigon that was
the only solution there had to be some
kind of negotiated settlement Johnson
believed that they he could crush I
really do believe Johnson believed he
could crush the National Liberation
Front militarily I think that u.s.
foreign policy has to rethink and think
think twice in three times before it and
barks on unilateral adventures in any
part of the world I think when Robert
Kennedy went to Europe in February 1967
he gauged the extent of the Western
Allies disagreement with the war in
Vietnam and what he found was that the
allies Italy France and England in
particular were all appalled about the
bombing of North Vietnam and the
violence that the United States had
unleashed there in Southeast Asia and it
was undermining America's credibility
with the allies I think what we had in
the in the Johnson White House was a
little bit of what Frederic Dutton who
was an aide to Robert Kennedy called in
an internal
- Robert Kennedy Texas nationalisms what
he called it and a kind of a
unilateralis tae dia the United States
could go in and remake Vietnam in any
image that it wanted to it was going
into a complicated environment the
politics in Saigon were as complex as
anything you would see today in Sarajevo
or Beirut and the United States was
going in there trying to militarily
crush groups and factions that needed to
be negotiated with and I if there are
any lessons from the Vietnam syndrome
and that would be the United States
should beware of acting unilaterally
militarily and the internal affairs of
foreign countries and that's just my
opinion I don't make that conclusion of
a book that's just response to a
question some more questions please
okay I wasn't gonna say that myself but
the the the last Texan that was at last
Texan in the White House was Lyndon
Johnson and and I will tell you this
Lyndon Johnson in April of 1965 a lot of
people don't really think about this
anymore but he sent 23,000 American
troops into the Dominican Republic like
that he and it was a very heavy-handed
kind of military operation right there
in in April of 65 unilateral use of
military force and Robert Kennedy came
out against it he came out against
Lyndon Johnson's invasion in the
Dominican Republic he said that it
violated the OAS Charter it lumped
non-communist nationalists with
communists it it was relied too heavily
on brute military force
you know Lyndon Johnson a parent
apparently I mean his foreign policy was
hawkish however you have to also realize
that Lyndon Johnson had lined up a
formidable array of folks backing his
Vietnam policy I mean he had Omar
Bradley and Dwight Eisenhower heroes
from World War two he had the chair you
know the chairs of the Armed Services
committees he had the afl-cio
George Meany they became very strong
supporters of the Vietnam War I mean he
had a bipartisan coalition to support
the Vietnam War it was a bipartisan war
when I hear the word bipartisanship I
don't necessarily think it's just
definitively always a good thing you
know you you hear in the news media
today well that let's be bipartisan this
should be bipartisan and that bipartisan
well the Vietnam War was bipartisan and
it was a national disaster in my opinion
and in Robert Kennedy's opinion at the
time so that's how I would
- that no other questions come on okay
come on come on up please
you've done a lot of really great
primary source research here I mean look
at all these wonderful photographs that
I assume have never been published
anywhere else before in any other book
or I mean can you talk a little bit
about writing and research and what it
feels like to sit in a library with
boxes full of documents and you know
I've done a little bit of primary source
research but it's really kind of I don't
know to me it's a really interesting
kind of thing to do but then you have to
go and sit down and write and and how
how does that feel and what is it like
to to then move from doing something
that's you feel like gosh I've got
something here you know sitting here at
this table in the Kennedy Library and
then I have to go and like put it into
words and the book is not short by any
means and it's chapter after chapter and
it's so knowledgeable and learn it so I
just wonder what it's like to do the
switch and how it felt thank you thank
you that this is my first book it was my
dissertation at Cornell and it was it
was an extraordinary experience and I
went into the Kennedy Library I spent a
semester there in the fall of 1994 I was
affiliated with Harvard and I went to
the Kennedy Library every day and went
through these boxes and boxes and boxes
of documents his Senate correspondences
presidential campaign paper everything
and then related you know I'm I can't
even tell you how many documents I went
through day in and day out I did it very
low-tech it was a lot of fun I actually
took notes on note cards you know and I
didn't have a laptop or anything fancy I
had a pencil and note cards and I I was
under the impression from the secondary
sources that I had read on Robert
Kennedy that Robert Kennedy didn't say
much about the Vietnam War you know from
65 to 67 let's say
No and that he kind of jumped in at 68
and then I was finding all of these
amazing strong statements he had been
saying all along and then these
correspondence with in my book I cite
extraordinary letters there's a letter
written by for African American GIs
from Vietnam to Robert Kennedy a few
days after they heard that Martin Luther
King was assassinated and it's a
poignant letter and I and I include the
entire letter and it's a tighter tyranny
as it was written I mean as it had been
written and there is letters from farm
workers in California and there was just
always correspondent I found that
Kennedy there were there were two
different correspondents going I was
very interesting there were
correspondents going on with all of
these just workers and peace activists
and students and poor people and then
there was this elite correspondence with
people like John Kenneth Galbraith and
Benjamin Spock and and McGeorge Bundy
and these these bigwigs you know and so
it was very it was very interesting to
see his correspondence and see that he
really was in a unique political
position and there and the researching
it was exciting it was fun I guess I'm a
geek because I really enjoyed the
research part but it was very
time-consuming I took you know note
cards of note I left with a big box of
no cries I went down to the Johnson
library xeroxed everything and I took
tons and tons of note cards and then
when I came back I made every mistake
you can make on a book you know I mean I
wrote chapters that were somewhere too
long somewhere too short it I kind of it
was like a scope it was like an artist
with a making a sculpture you know what
I mean I was chipping away chipping away
and finally it became what I'm very
proud of this book I went through 1,200
photographs at the Kennedy Library
narrowed it down to about 60 and then
narrow those down to about 16 and most
of these have never been published
anywhere and then I wrote the captions
for the photos it was really fun and I
just found that I cast a wide net and
through doing the research it was it was
it was a real kind of
I wrote I wrote a book that had that
it's never been written before you know
I the the his Robert Kennedy's relations
with those social movements of that
period combining a social history with
his leadership role in the years 65 to
68 it hadn't been written yet and I did
it and I in it and I felt it felt really
good to finally see it in it final form
you know and I had great advice from
professors at Cornell who read my
chapters and I would just like to say on
that note if they're if there's no more
questions
that I would just like to thank all of
you again for coming out and hearing my
presentation and I hope you get
something out of the book that you
didn't know about the 60s and about
about Robert F Kennedy and I want to
thank the Booker again L so the Tompkins
County Library for hosting this event
thank you